[Music]
as the coronavirus vaccine
is being rolled out explaining how it
works is vital when it comes to winning
public trust
that is why these scientists have taken
matters into their own hands
using tick tock to answer all sorts of
questions relating to the vaccine in
order to promote
confidence it is likely that the vaccine
will reduce the amount of viruses
present in the lungs
and therefore the montevides is expelled
from the lungs we make these
short videos that say um this is
what people are saying this is what the
actual truth is
um we want to get the right information
across and we want to help people i get
this question a lot
dr paul mckay is a research scientist of
30 years
and he's now a bit of a tick-tock star
these videos
he and his colleagues have been
uploading tackling misinformation
have already topped more than 20 million
views you need somebody who actually has
made a vaccine someone like myself
to say no we didn't put microchips into
that that's false
and that's all we can say that 5g isn't
going to control your mind if you get
this vaccine
according to the world health
organization social media is being used
during the pandemic to amplify an
infodemic
of misinformation around a vaccine as
well as coronavirus
so that's why experts are now turning to
platforms like tiktok
in order to fight back when he's not
teaching professor palier
is creating short videos addressing the
concerns about
everything vaccine related but using
poetry
scientists have not rested only science
can usher
that universal sigh of relief
our students saw a challenge but they
did not flinch
i do think that we are trying to counter
people
who are trying to invoke fear and
that's not their goal i understand why
some people have fear too
right that's not the issue i would have
fear to in certain circumstances
i just think having information is good
for everyone
the online world has become a place of
misinformation
and the government is trying to find new
ways to tackle the problem
but with one video at a time these
scientists are doing their bit
to change the narrative noel phillips
sky news